كذا وزير الخارجيه الكويتيه الشيخ سالم
العبد الله مواصله محادثات بلاده مع
العراق لانهاء ملف ترسيم الحدود هذا ولم
تعمد الامم المتحده منذ التسعينات منذ
التسعينات الى ترسيم الحدود البحريه
بكاملها وتركت المهمه للبلدين وكان رئيس
مجلس الوزراء الكويتيه الشيخ احمد النواب
قد طالبه خلال مؤتمر بغداد الذي عقد في
عمان باغلاق كافه الملفات العالقه لاسيه
ما استكمال ترسيم الحدود البحريه بعد
العلامه 100
و26
احنا الحين في محدثات مع الجانب العراق
والنوايا كلها طيبه اعتقد وان شاء الله
نتواصل الى الاتفاق بالنسبه انهاء ترسيم
الحدود اللي هو الموضوع جدا مهم بالنسبه
للاخواننا العراقين اكيد
نظام الينا من الكويت وزير العالم الاسبق
سامي النصف سيد سامي مساء الخير مرحبا بك
معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض وزير
الخارجيه الكويتيه يقول بانها المحدثات
مستمره ويبدو ان هناك يعني وليد لحسن
النوايا بين البلدين هذا الملف ملف ترسيم
الحدود برايك لماذا لم يحسم هذا الملف حتى
هذه اللحظه سيد سامي
اخي الفاضل انا اتصور انه عدم حسمه حتى
هذه اللحظه لا يعني انه لن يحسم مستقبلا
اتصور انه اذا حسنت النوايا يمكن حسم هذا
الموضوع في دقائق او حتى ثواني يعني
القضيه محسومه الحدود بين البلدين رسمت
بناءا على قرارات الامم المتحده وترك
الباقي للمحادثات الثنائيه ولا همم نتوقع
او نرجوا ان يتدخل حتى طرف ثالث فيها لانه
بامكان حلها بشكل واضح ما عليك الا ان
تنظر للتاريخ للخرائط الخرائط تظهر بشكل
تام ان للعراق منافذ بحريه ولديها ميناء
الفاو الكبير ولديها منفذ كامل على الخليج
وبالتالي ليست في حاجه الى قضايا صغيره
هنا او هناك الكويت كذلك لديها من حسن
النوايا اتجاه الشقيقه الاكبر العراق
الكثير انما هناك بعض منقصات الصغيره نسمع
بقضايا تهريب مخدرات سلاح تيريها وبالتالي
يحتاج الامر بين حين واخر
متابع ان ان اسال عنه يعني هذه القضايا
العالقه والقضايا اللي انت تسمي بانها
قضايا ربما صغيره لكن هي قضايا الصيادين
تهريب المخدرات والاسلحه ايضا كذلك وعدد
يعني ربما من القضايا التي لا تدخل مباشره
في الملاحه همم البحريه لكن لا زالت علقه
بين البلديه لايمده هذه قد تعرقل الوصول
لاي اتفاق تدفع ايضا بتدخل طرف ثالث لحل
هذه المشكله
يعني سؤال هام متى ما اتفقنا وهذه حقيقه
انه لا توجد اشكالات بقضيه الملاحه تبقى
القضايا الهامشيه الجانبيه هذه اعتقد انه
لا خلاف بين دولتين كما يفترض في قضايا
تهريب مخدرات اسلحه وغيرها من انشطه غير
مشروعه وبالتالي للعراق مصلحه كما حال
الكويت في قضيه السيطره والتمكن من هذه
الامور العراق من الدول التي دفعت اثمان
باهظه على الخلافات الحدوديه نتذكر خلاف
شط العرب وحرب ثمان سنوات لتنتهي بعد ذلك
همم يعني اتفاق على العوده الى الاتفاق
الجزائر الذي منزق عام 80 وسنه حرب ل 80
سنوات ودفعت العثمان بها انا اتصور ان
العراق الجديد العراق الشقيق اللي الان
نحن على ابواب دوره الخليج والكويت مساهمه
بقواها ناعمه سواء القوى الدبلوماسيه او
القوى الاعلاميه في دعم والدفع بالعراق
للعوده الى الى مكانته الطبيعيه بالاقليم
ضمن الجامعه العربيه وضمن المنظومات
الدوليه يعني هذه الحدود رسمت رسمت مرتين
يعني قرانا ونعرف تاريخيا هي رسمت مرتين
بعد الغزو الكويتي في عهد النظام العراقي
السابق عهد صدام حسين وكذلك ايضا في 2013
وبعد ذلك عادت هذه المشكله لتطفوا على سطح
مره اخرى يعود الحديث
لترسيم الحدود ولا تحدث هنا عن الملاحه
البحريه او تنظيمها فقط وهذه الاتفاقيه
والحسمت باتفاقيات مجلس الامن واتفاقات
الامميه وتم التوافق لماذا الان يعود مره
اخرى للحديث على نفس النقطه التي تم
الاتفاق عليها اصلا بقرار امي
نعم هذه القضيه الحاسمه جدا يعني قضيه
ابقاء هذه الملفات دون حجم وهي لا تتعلق
الا بعلامات حدوديه بعد العلامه 162
يبقيها ماده للمزايدات السياسيه بين احزاب
مختلفه بين ملكيات وغيرها وبالتالي انا
اتصور انه على العراق ان يرفع شعار صفر
مشاكل بعد ان جرب قضيه المشاكل مع الجيران
ودفعه الاثمان باهضه من ارزاق ودماء الشعب
العراقي انا الان حان الوقت ان تصفر هذه
المشاكل حتى لا تبقى
وسيله للمزايدات للاطراف يعني المتخندقه
ضمن الداخل العراقي انا اتصور انه
العلاقات بين الكويت والعراق وصلت الى
مراحل ما عدا لاشكال صغير كهذا ان يوقفها
والان كما ذكرت نحن امام ابواب دوره
الخليج امام امر اخر متعلق بالخليج كما
حدث في البيان
يعني اللي تم في مؤتمر بغداد عقده في عمان
اليوم في عمان اليوم الكويت هي ضمن ست دول
خليجيه والعراق تاريخيا جربت توجه شمالا
ثم قربا ثم شرقا انا اعتقد حان الوقت
للعراق للاستفاده الكامله من العلاقه مع
السد والخليجيه وسمعنا وراينا بادره
الامير المجدد سمو الامير محمد بن سلمان
بالانفتاح الكامل على العراق المملكه
والكويت تمثل ضمن نقطه
ما ذكرتهم على العراق ربما في ال ال
المنطقه يقوده ولي العهد السعودي الامير
محمد بن سلمان وكذلك ايضا حتى الدول
الخليجيه تبحث في هذه الفرص لكن ماذا عن
العراق هل العراق اليوم منفتح على الاقل
لا تحدث عن جواره همم بشكل عام تحدث عن
قضيه ترسيمه الحدود مع الكويت هل هو منفتح
عليها الان باعتقادك سيد سامي
انا والله اتصور الامر كذلك لانه ما هو
البديل يعني البديل ان تبقى الحاله متازمه
مع الكويت وهذا امر جرب ودفعت الاثمان
باهظه من قبل العراق ومن قبل الكويت كذلك
هناك الجار الجنوبي اللي هو عباره عن ست
دول هي اصبحت اقرب للقدوه في المنطقه
بالتقدم والتنميه والسياحه وغيرها
وبالتالي العراق عندما يصفي مشاكل مع
الكويت ومع غيره من جيران انا اعتقد
سيستفيد استفاده كبرى بعمليات التنميه
والاستفاده من هذه الجيره الرائعه مع ست
دول خليجيه منجزه يعني شاهدنا الدوره في
قطر شاهدنا ما يحدث قبل ذلك في في
الامارات والمملكه وبقيه دول الخليج
وبالتالي هناك استفاده للعراق على العراق
ان يتحول من علاقه الخساره الخساره مع
الجيران الى علاقه الربح الربح واول لها
تصفيه هذه المشاكل وتصفير هذه
تحول بعد ذلك لقضيه تعزيز العمليات
التعاون التي نكتب منها اليوم تعلم بقضيه
الربط الكهربائي بين جنوب العراق اللي راح
يستفيد منه استفاده كامله مع دول الخليج
وعلى راسها الكويت وبالتالي هذه العلاقه
اللي نتمناها وهذه العلاقه لان انت تتقدم
الى الامام في بقاء هذه المنتجات او
المنقصات في العلاقه العراقيه الكويتيه
انا لدي ثقه كامله بالقياده السياسيه في
الكويت والعراق
انا اشكرك شكرا
من الوقت من الكويت وزير الاعلام الاسبق
سامح الناس شكرا لك